in our morning rounds a major new effort
to discourage children and teenagers
from using e-cigarettes this morning the
American Academy of Pediatrics called
for new federal regulations including
setting a minimum age of 21 to buy the
products banning online sales and youth
targeted marketing and stopping
production of certain flavored cigarette
products the AAP says quote the
increasing use of e-cigarettes among
youth threatens five decades of public
health gains our dr. taryn and Rula is
here good morning good morning look at
the numbers east cigarette use up 78%
among high school students just in the
past year is it an epidemic let me put
this in perspective for you in March the
American Academy of Pediatrics and other
organizations like the American Cancer
Society the AAA sued the FDA saying they
are not doing enough in terms of
regulating e-cigarettes they have
delayed what we call pre-market approval
until 2022 and it is an epidemic the
Surgeon General said that in fact it is
it is affecting 3.6 million youth
they're the ones that are users about
20% of high school students 5 percent of
middle school students and we know that
it's not just the harms of the
e-cigarettes but it's the fact that it
is a gateway to traditional cigarette
use I wasn't creases that I was
surprised when the pediatrician asked my
10 year olds if they had ever used an
e-cigarette so pediatricians are
unnoticed describe the health dangers
right well there are a lot so let's
start with just nicotine itself we know
that nicotine is extremely addictive
whether you use it once or twice or for
a couple weeks you can become addicted
the amount of nicotine that kids are
getting from these east cigarettes may
be much more than they would get from
traditional cigarettes in fact one of
these pods has as much nicotine as a
whole pack of cigarettes nicotine is
cardiovascular side effects and it
affects the adolescent brain the brain
develops until the age of 25 and
nicotine has the potential to change
learning memory impulse control it also
can affect mood disorders increasing the
risk of who deserves and primed the
brain for risk of addiction to other
substances now let's talk about what
else is in the e-cigarettes besides
nicotine ultrafine particles that can be
irritants or affect the lungs the
flavorings which we think are generally
recognized as safe for ingestion may not
be safe for inhalation there are
toxins carcinogens there's also risks of
accidental ingestion of the liquid that
has led to poison control calls many of
them as well as burns and fires I mean
the list
I mean you are doing a really good job
describing how dangerous this yeah what
are the effects on bystanders like
secondhand smoke from these there's not
been a lot of study looking into that be
honest oh we really don't know but
certainly that does linger in the air
and there could very well be effects on
bystanders and again the point is some
of this damage to either the lungs of
the brain you can traverse right so I
don't think so yeah we haven't studied
in a long-term what about parents we
have a teenager and what can they do
right so parents can do a lot and so the
AAP says look parents should really be
screening talking to their kids and
saying you know are you using
e-cigarettes have you been around them
and if they are why why are using this
and then helping to get them help if
they need help and not importantly
punishing them but recognizing that this
is a health problem it is an addiction
and unfortunately we don't have a lot of
treatments for kids who are hooked to
vaping we don't have the same kind of
treatments like we might offer adults in
terms of nicotine replacement therapy
patches etc or medications they just
haven't been approved for kids I think
that point that you make is a really
good one explaining that the adolescent
mind is developing until the age of 25
so any of the toxins carcinogens
stimulants that you place in that brain
are gonna affect you for life but what's
so unfortunate is that the marketing to
kids has been so aggressive marketing on
television which is not allowed for
traditional cigarettes marketing through
social media at sporting events some
even offer bachelor's scholarships to
kids it is not a benign habit no Tara
thank you